so geht's noch halbwegs und wir gucken
jetzt mal was man mit der 50 prozent
challenge erreichen kann in jump league
dpa
servus und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video gespielt heute wieder auf
play marty jump league sowie im letzten
video auch hören wollte keinen komischen
wave shader der uns das ganze ding
verhagelt wir haben stattdessen eine
challenge die ich vom play meinert
server bekommen ab gewissermaßen und
zwar habe ich in der lobby gechillt
die leute einfach in der lobby auf
plenty mal gefragt so läuft ihr später
die ganze zeit im blick was denkt ihr
was für eine coole jump blick und
gemeinden probiere mal aus nur jede
zweite kiste mitzunehmen
das hier war die erste die lassen wir
aus als jede zweite kiste wird dann
folglich auch ausgelassen die ihr
gefährt wieder nehmen und die
darauffolgende dann wieder nicht ist
eigentlich ziemlich ist schnell erklärt
challenge aber macht die sache schwierig
wenn man nur 50 prozent
das equipment hat oder 50 prozent der
chancen so der glut ich muss nämlich
auch höllisch aufpassen dass ich nicht
aus versehen die zum beispiel mit nehme
da weil dann die ja geschummelt
schumann ist doof das wissen wir alle
genau deswegen machen wir das nicht aber
das gute ist so man keine kisten nutzt
spart man sich zeit
ganz einfach man kann das modul viel mut
fertig laufen wenn man einfach nicht für
die kiste stehen bleibt dann ist auch
ein besseres gefühl
aber er hat halt kein kisten geblutet
und das ist auch nicht so geil
zwei dinge sind neue leute hat
wahrscheinlich gemerkt minecraft sieht
gerade ein bisschen anders aus als es
davor aus ab und zwar habe ich heute
einen neuen schwereren den platz eins
aus meiner feder vorstellung
falls sie nicht gesehen habt hier oben
sie verlinkt noch mal könnt euch nochmal
anschauen da waren ziemlich cool shader
dabei der platz eins ist der ku'damm
medium shader und den habe ich heute
auch hier in diesem video verwendet um
etwa jetzt darf ich das nicht darf nicht
verstecken habe ich die kiste blutet
niemand schreibt viel glück escape chat
habe ich die kiste hier geleitet oder
nicht ja und davor war davor kam genau
das andere ok da bis nicht gebucht alles
klar
man muss demnächst wieder auslassen wie
gesagt ich muss höllisch aufpassen
faircheck das viel zu schnell wenn man
so im überfluss ist und sich den mund
fusselig geredet darauf aufzupassen dass
man nicht nicht die kiste ist gar nicht
so ist
ja genau also neue schilder schreibt
meine kommentare von dem ihr haltet ich
mag den wenn euch auch gefällt kann man
ihn drin lassen
sehr schön aber okay das ist gar nicht
so easy das modul jetzt muss ich mich
auf die kiste drauf stellen aber da sind
lupen dankeschön leute ja das macht
teilweise auch schon ein bisschen
traurig muss man sagen und dann haben
wir das ja auch okay jetzt wird man die
nächste wieder aufmachen so die letzte
partie ausgelassen die dadurch wieder
öffnen
gut wir haben sogar schon ein stein
schwert das ist gar nicht so schlecht
zack zack zack lasst uns aber versuchen
noch ein bisschen weiter zu kommen denn
je weiter wir kommen desto besser das
equipment auch über nur ihre fertig ist
mit dem dorf an dem leitsatz verändert
sich nichts was ich aber noch verändert
leute neben dem shader ist die musik
jetzt ist nicht nur die shader verändert
sich wollte ich sagen leute sondern auch
die musik inwiefern ich war schon länger
so nicht ganz zufrieden meiner musik
muss ich sagen
also ich hatte immer ein paar tracks
aber die wirklich coolen tricks war halt
immer copyright und ein bisschen doof
deswegen habe ich okay dafür muss jetzt
weiter aus leute ich schaue ja auch
casey leistet also dass ein blogger aus
new york ist ziemlich bekannt momentan
ziemlich gehabt und dann hat immer
richtig coole musik in seinen blogs
mensch wie wie schafft er das coole
musik hatten kann es ja nicht auch haben
und dann habe ich mir mal ein paar von
den leuten rausgesucht deren musik
verwendet und habe die mal angeschrieben
so nach dem motto einfach ganz frech
geschrieben so hey ich bin deutscher
youtube wird deine musik auch gerne
verwenden und tatsächlich haben sich da
ein paar gemeldet mit positiven
rückmeldungen unter anderem der mensch
dessen musik jetzt heute hier verwendet
habt android heißt er danke an dich ende
das ist in deutschland kommt das
augsburg aus dass deutschland es voll
witzig und er macht macht musik die von
casey leistet in aus new york verwendet
wird was vor wird verrückt ist aber okay
dazu welche darauf ich jetzt nicht näher
eingehen auf jeden fall hat dieser
android weiß nicht sein kann ich den
richtigen vornamen den künstlernamen wie
die erlaubnis erteilt seine musik zu
hören oder ihr hört die musik im
hintergrund und ich finde die musik
ziemlich geil was ihr davon findet
wieder unten in die kommentare
damit ihr möglichkeit habt hier
mitzubestimmen
laden leute wenn sich dinge verändern
dann hole ich mir immer noch ganz gern
mal eine zweite meinung von zuschauer
ein sowohl erde ist der das bild sieht
und die musik hört okay die nächste
kiste da hab ich nicht mehr bluten
ich wollte jetzt kurz noch mal anmerken
dass mein nickname einfach asian
sensation ist also die asiatische
sensation weil es irgendwie diesem porno
titel klingt klingt wie ein film in dem
ich mir eigentlich nicht anschauen will
er ist jetzt ein kleiner schwer der ba
sieht das ist extrem dunkel hierbei die
kiste die wir aber nicht nehmen dürfen
so jetzt nicht die augen allzu sehr zu
kneifen wenn man aus der dunkelheit ins
helle kommen zum zug kommt der shader um
die ecke das ist wunderschön scheint da
denn im block an die sonne kommt um die
ecke nicht der shader so er ist sieht
gut aus 98 zu 48 können wir jetzt für
eine schön es hat nicht gereicht
er schreibt aber finde ich dass ein
arschloch als optisch wird sagen die
hunde da waren uns also das sollten wir
wünschen können das teilt jetzt hat er
den gästen geladen
scheinbar dabei bleibt problem mit dem
laden gehabt jetzt geht's wieder mit den
laden so jetzt mal kurz konzentrieren
dann finde ich mal dieses münchen auch
mal ganz lockt ja wohl sehr schön da ist
es ja ich würde sagen unser equipment
ist ziemlich sonne dafür dass werder nur
jede zweite kiste gehört haben sechs
äpfel sind unser einziger fukushima vor
wir hätten diese äpfel nicht dann hätten
wir ein richtiges problem so geht's noch
halbwegs wir gucken jetzt mal was man
mit der 50 prozent challenge erreichen
kann in jump the death match das ist
halt diese cd map nur die kennt hier
habe ich früher mal darauf gespielt
black ops genau black ops auf der xbox
sind wir immer auf dieser map gespielt
ihr wisst schon immer mal mit freunden
gezockt die unterschiedlichen teams so
und in dem alter der schon rausgeflogen
okay da bediene ich mich gerne war am
fuß ansonsten hat er nicht sparen das
für mich ja die asian sensation kommt
jetzt auf weiteres ein ok
lol alter wieder durch die gegend liegt
ach du scheiße entschuldigt dass flug
aber der legt wirklich irre durch die
gegend habe ich jetzt getötet ich glaub
ja ok kopper zeiten die richtung häufig
bei mir ganz wichtig leute zu den themen
musik und shader warum legen die so die
länge alle wie hölle immer witzig ist
auch wenn man es hier lang läuft und
über den eigenen kopf des diese dummies
von yoji plugin gespannt werden dann
werfen natürlich auch einen schatten
weil die auf die spieler angezeigt
werden
ich weiß nicht ob ich es gesehen habe da
gerade am boden sein ganzes team aus
vollkommen vom taunus getötet
ehrlichkeit getötet es ist ein ernst bis
ich mit mir anlegen
da kommt weiß was jetzt passiert ist
bist du weg zack zack weg mit ihr warm
so ist nicht ganz weg noch ein leben und
kommt einer hatte jetzt kann man hier
kurz an eben keine fehler müssen jetzt
voll rein und einfach zähne
zusammenbeißen koffer packen sehr schön
auch den haben wir
und hier ist normal ich würde schon
sagen ich hab dir bußgeld verdeckt je
eher sinken wieder mal ganz großer
durchblick jetzt könnte der ecke
reagiert und schön block immer dann
haben wir auch schnell weg alles klar
soll die runde läuft wirklich gut ist
sieht fast so aus als könnten wir das
gewinnen
trotz 50 prozent der kosten jetzt wo wir
uns den hier alle genauso teilen dass er
dagegen die decke gepustet wird und dann
kommt da nicht weg wir haben ihn oder
kommt direkt der nächste ist es der
letzte gegner ja gewissermaßen letzte
gegner wartet noch zwei level leben
jetzt nur noch ein leben so was hat man
hier ist die arena ist kann ich
gebrauchen
und ja den entscheid da nicht wirklich
aber ich nehme man mit so leute immer
noch ein gegner und guckt euch mal die
map an
das sieht mit shader so geil aus schaut
man nach links links ist bei euch ich
weiß lass es lieber schaut euch einfach
nach beiden seiten um das hier sieht
voll cool aus ich habe auch den bug mit
diesen weißen linien weg bekommen danke
für die tipps sie mir da gegeben wurden
so jetzt gehen wir immer schon eine
combo atem haben wird es nicht mehr
aber wir können glaube ich ganz gut an
abziehen so wunderbar die runde was mit
die war wirklich gut und ich habe ich
auch glaube ich nicht verkackt also ich
hab nicht geschummelt oder das auch im
kommentar schreiben musik shader
challenge alles klar
das war's von mir wenn die challenger
den hat gerne in die kommentare damit
und bis zum nächsten mal